you know for a lot of our viewers you
are the face of the stress the
disruption that they're going to face
next week whether that is children
trying to go to exams whether it's
adults trying to get to work or hospital
appointments whether it's people
hundreds of thousands of people trying
to go to glastonbury what would you say
to them
well we don't want to be the cause of
the disruption in people's lives we want
a settlement to this dispute but we're
facing a crisis for our members we're
faced with thousands of job cuts despite
what grant shap says there's been no
guarantee that these redundancies won't
be compulsory we've seen
four or five thousand jobs already go
from the railway they've told our
maintenance staff
uh on rail network rail that their three
thousand jobs will go
they're going to cut back on the safety
regime they've told us that every single
booking office in britain will close
they've told us that they're going to
extend the working week from 35 hours to
40 or possibly 44 and for new entrants
that will mean lower wages so they're
actually proposing pay cuts not a pay
rise and an increase in working time on
the railway and if that's the way the
rest of the society is going to go that
you have to work more hours for less
money we've got a real crisis in this
country because it means they're trying
to restore profit in a way that makes
workers pay for that
through their pace pay bills and through
their
wage slips and through the amount of
time they're going to spend in the
workplace at the same time though a lot
of people work more than 35 hours a week
and a lot of people are going to be
facing in fact most of it is a real
terms pay cut because of inflation are
you not asking for special treatment
here no we're not asking for special
treatment we've had pay cuts we most of
our members have not had a pay rise for
two to three years i'm talking about
actual pay cuts the reduction of
salaries as well as the losses against
the rate of inflation which has been
said is 11 at the moment so it's not
just a losing out against the cost of
living they're actually proposing to cut
pay on the railway going forward that
was a proposal to put to us by the train
operating companies on thursday and
since that time they've not invited us
to any meetings whatsoever just just to
be clear on this because the reports
that i've read uh are saying uh that the
train offering 18 companies are offering
around two point five percent because no
offer and you uh are gunning for uh
eleven percent pay wise is that true
neither of those things is true what is
true the train operating companies have
made no offer at all right during these
talks there are two strands of talks
network rail have got a strand which is
about half the people and the train
operators the train operators adjourn
the meeting on thursday they've not
invited us to any talks whatsoever and
they've made no offer on pay and what
they told us is what they plan to do and
what are you looking for on pay we're
looking for a pay rise that reflects the
cost of living so what does that mean
well that's the choice let's be really
clear what are you asking for at the
time of the network rail pay deal that
should have been done in december
it was 7.1 percent the retail price
index let's not forget that those
members didn't get a pay rise last year
either so is that what you're looking
for that's what we that's what the cost
of living would have been at the time
these deals should have been struck so
we're going to negotiate to see if we
can get a deal that reflects that cost
of living there are a number of ways
which you can put value into a package
it's not all about straightforward pay
so we'll talk to them constructively but
they're making offers that are nowhere
near there and for half the people in
the distribute there's no offer at all
and for many of them it's the third year
where there's no offer and no proposal
now grant shaps makes a point about the
amount of taxpayers money that is going
into the railways currently right and of
course we know through kovid that uh
taxpayers have to bankroll uh the
railways
and also less people go into the office
and so uh around 75 percent i think is
the sort of capacity on the railways he
says you know the government has spent
uh 16 billion pounds on railways and
start the pandemic 600 pounds per
household are you not effectively asking
taxpayers to bankroll salaries we're not
that 16 billion was at the peak of covid
where there are only three or four
percent of people traveling on the
railway our members worked through that
and they the government insisted that
the railways be kept open we worked with
them on that and that was the last time
i met grant chaps to talk about working
practices and the way that we could keep
the railway open so when they say we
didn't get furlough the reason we didn't
get furloughed is we kept working every
day every shift seven days a week the
point he's making is that actually we're
talking about taxpayers i'll come to
that so at that time there was there was
a subsidy but let's not forget during
that period these train operating
companies and the rolling stock leasing
companies and the subcontractors made
500 million pounds of profit in the
worst year for rail revenue so what
grant chaps is actually doing is
subsidising private sector profit
dividends and shares two of the
companies that i'm dealing with in this
dispute first group and go ahead are
subject to takeover bids of billions of
pounds they're really attractive to
private sector investors and they want
to take them over because they know that
there's going to be profit even while
the railway's subsidised it's not
actually true that they have been
subsidised to that level before kovid
they were subsidised by 6.4 billion and
then in the covered period they had to
add to that to keep it open because
there was no revenue and what these
trade operating companies said was if
you don't give us money for the
emergency measures we're going to give
you the keys back so that the state can
run the railway and that would have been
a more efficient way to run it actually
because that would have saved 500
million pounds of profit that's going
out to these companies so you can't have
it both ways he's claiming that uh
workers are subsidised while he's
subsidising dividends and shares well um
do you ever worry
with the big strikes happening
that there's a risk that you're over
playing your hand grant shaps has said
and he said the program earlier that
workers shouldn't risk striking
themselves out of a job we know that the
government is looking at changing some
of the legislation around strike so that
you know it's easier for workers to come
in to cover uh striking workers also
potentially increasing the damages that
companies can get back from unions for
illegal strikes do you worry we don't
take part in illegal strikes this is a
lawful ballot conducted under this tory
government's anti-union legislation but
do you think that you might be
overplaying your hand and you're
basically going to battle with the
government and there will be a backlash
well if we don't play our hand thousands
of my members will lose their jobs
railway services will be cut back the
safety regime that has been in place for
a good deal of time will be cut back 50
percent of the maintenance on the
railway infrastructure is scheduled to
be cut so that he can cut three thousand
of our members jobs so we have to fight
this because we haven't had any pay
rises
we're faced with thousands of job cuts
and they want to rip up our terms and
conditions in a form of fire and re-hire
that's internal to the railway it's just
as ruthless as p o really but they
haven't got agency workers to come in so
they're saying to our people you have to
entirely change the way you work and if
you're a new entrant you'll have to work
longer and for less money and what
they've also thrown on the table this
week in both london underground and the
railway pension scheme is that the
pensions of our members are going to be
decimated they're going to make us
poorer not only while we're at work but
poorer in retirement
and that's an agenda that the government
has got because they want to subsidise
the private sector in this country as
they are doing in the health service
which is being consumed by the private
sector as they've done in the education
service which is being consumed by the
private sector all of which are farming
subsidy direct into their dividends and
shareholders but it's pretty clear that
you're not going to back away from
strike action at sitting here it's it
that is more than clear i just wanted
three we're available to negotiate
sophie this this not something that we
didn't attend uh negotiations yesterday
which grant chapters just said on your
program is an entire fabrication we left
network rail on friday night
around half past seven and they said to
us we are prepared to meet you on sunday
they never mentioned any negotiations on
saturday because they were going to
speak to the department for transport
about what they might be able to discuss
with us so he's like he's making it up
he's lying well he's making it up what
he's saying is untrue we didn't
attend a rally instead of negotiations
there were no negotiations scheduled and
the train operating companies have not
spoken to me or any of my officials
since thursday at lunchtime
throwing forward
could we see more strikes over the
summer and and what kind of consequences
could they have grant chaps are saying
that luke fright will still be running
we're not in a situation where you know
the lights could go out is he right
well i don't want the lights to go out
nobody from my side of the situation has
said the lights will go out we know they
will run a train service using
replacement labor many of whom are
unqualified to do the work and have had
very short uh two or three-hour training
programs too
multiple strikes
if there's not a settlement we will
continue our campaign
i know that the as left
another union is balloting their members
and their returns on july the 11th the
tssa which is largely a management union
in the railway is also balloting their
members in network rail and in many of
the train operating companies it's
likely that unite that has some
engineering members in the railway will
also ballot but i think there are going
to be many unions balloting
across the country because people can't
take it anymore we've got people who are
doing full-time jobs who are having to
take state benefits and use food banks
that is a national disgrace and grant
chaps is fairly blase about that he's
claiming that everybody on the railway
is overpaid and sitting around doing
nothing our members the median wage in
this dispute is 31 000 pounds many of
the people on strike next week are
earning as low as eighteen thousand and
typically many of them were earning in
the mid twenties you think full-time
jobs working shifts around the clock you
think this is a class struggle class war
well there's a class aspect to
everything in the economy there are
lower paid people and there are wealthy
people in this society and what's wrong
in this society is that there is an
imbalance between the people that do the
work
to keep this country going who create
the wealth of our civilization and don't
get a fair share of that wealth because
it's going to people who are vastly
wealthy where do you think labour are
currently on this class struggle i don't
know where labour are if somebody could
tell me where labour are i'd be very
happy to hear it i think they're
triangulating between what they think is
public opinion in the likes of the daily
mail and the commentary in this country
but what they've got to do and what i
want them to do and i want kirsten to be
successful and i want him to be our next
prime minister
is con get back in contact with working
people working people are suffering
there's really poor employment practice
in this country many people are in
vulnerable jobs with low pay and he's
got to come up with a program that
identifies himself and the labour
party's policies directly with those
working people so that they can get
behind him and the trade union movement
can get fully behind him i mean where
streeting the shadow health secretary
reportedly apologized in shadow cabinet
for saying that if he was an rmt member
he would be voting for strike action
well if he anyone was an rnt member
they'd be voting for strike action you
look at the ballot
we had 89 percent of our members do you
think that should be more comfortable
about saying that publicly that's what
they labor should be comfortable with
backing working-class people who are
struggling and one of the ways that they
can redress the imbalance is through
industrial action where negotiations
fail
what else are we to do are we to plead
are we to beg
we want to bargain
for our futures we want to negotiate and
if we're not bargaining you have to beg
and i don't want any working-class
people in this country to have to beg
the employers for a decent living and
kirstama shouldn't want that either so
if we don't have industrial action and
we don't have that
attempt to rebalance society
what is it we do do we just accept mass
redundancies and our people getting
poorer year by year which is the
situation since cameron and osborne got
elected public sector workers have been
robbed of wages whether they're in the
military the police force the health
service the care service education all
of those people are getting poorer every
year and it's this government that's
responsible for it and if kia stammer
can't find the imagination to find which
side of the equation he needs to be on
he needs to think about where the labour
party is going and i hope he can succeed
in that you say that you would like him
to be the next prime minister do you
think he's on track to be the next prime
minister well i hope so i want a labour
government i want the labour government
that can deliver
a pro-working people agenda and that
means a lot of things it means funding
the public services properly but it also
means reconfiguring our cities and our
towns so that our people can get decent
council housing it means we have a good
transport system it means we have a good
environment and the railways are a key
part of that but in many of our towns
and villages and cities people are cut
off by high transport fares by high
service costs for everything that they
do now he's got to find a way of
creating policies that address that
situation and i hope he can succeed well
he hasn't produced policies they're in
that position where they're in purdue as
they call it on policy but i think he's
got to come out with some policies that
show he's on the side of working people